ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
says his troops are engaged in fierce
fighting for every single meter of
severe donetsk ukraine says russia has
destroyed all but one bridge out of the
city leaving few options for anyone
hoping to leave sevilla donetsk
together with neighboring lushansk are
the last main areas in luhansk province
not under russian control
ukrainian fighters say they're holding
out but without more long-range weapons
and even basic ammunition from the west
the tide could be turning in russia's
favor
smoke rising from an industrial area in
the city of sierra donetsk the last part
still under ukrainian control
this unverified footage reportedly shows
the azot chemical factory where hundreds
of fighters and residents are said to be
taking shelter
russia is trying to pound the city along
with neighbouring lizzy chansk into
submission with heavy artillery
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
says russia is throwing everything into
the battle
the occupiers key tactical goal has not
changed they are pressing into sierra
donetsk severe fighting is going on
there literally every meter
local officials say russian forces have
blown up a bridge linking several danes
with lesii chance cutting off a crucial
evacuation route for civilians
in lissy chansk ukraine is scrambling to
evacuate residents
many there think it's now time to get
out before it's too late
but we do hope to come back
meanwhile the west of ukraine is still
seeing russian rockets too
these images were reportedly taken after
a missile attack in the city of
moscow says it destroyed a large weapons
depot there
but for now russia's focus remains on
the donbass region
and while ukrainian forces have stopped
the russian advance so far keeve says it
needs more help from the west and has
renewed its pleas for more heavy weapons
dw correspondent nick connolly is in
central ukraine in the town of
kropinitsky
nick the fighting seems to be coming to
a head in eastern ukraine particularly
sevilla donetsk where do things stand
there now
well definitely this battle force
several of the nets has been going on
for weeks and many times before you've
had military experts saying that now is
the time now the last few days of
ukrainian control of several other nets
and then we've seen reverses in fortune
the ukrainians taking a bit more of the
town center moving out from the kind of
industrial outskirts where they've been
pushed back to but it does seem that now
this is the
end or almost the end for ukrainian
control on that bank of the river um
this was ukraine's last biggest outpost
on the northern bank of the civilization
river crucial defensive feature there
and with the news the russians have
blown up as we're hearing here in
ukraine today two bridges leaving only
one connection across the river
obviously supplying those ukrainian
forces on the other bank will be
increasingly difficult if not impossible
and it looks like ukrainian commanders
might eventually now take decision to
pull back pull back to the other bank of
the river which is a high bank with kind
of cliffs which is more easily
defendable and would allow ukraine to
basically cut its losses and to prevent
even further human losses especially a
situation where they're really having to
weigh up every bit of artillery every
bit of ammunition that they use because
they're in such a weaker position
compared to the russians in terms of the
resources at their disposal we've heard
from
ukrainian sources in the last few days
that basically their entire supply of
pre-war soviet-made ammunition is now
more or less used up and all they are
using now all they have at the disposal
is either
soviet caliber missiles and artillery
those come from eastern europe from from
poland from bulgaria from other nato
members or now nato
caliber weapons coming from the us the
uk and others so basically a very
difficult situation now where ukraine's
logistics are very very difficult and
crucial basically to them being able to
hold on to where they are right now in
donbass
dw's nick conley there reporting from
central ukraine
well frank ledwich is a military analyst
and former intelligence officer with the
british army he joins us now from oxford
england frank ukraine says it
desperately needs more military hardware
and not just heavy weapons but basic
supplies like ammunition just how
under-equipped are the ukrainians at
this stage
they use thousands of shells every day
in what has been since the start and
remains essentially an artillery battle
and the problem they face in artillery
battles is every shell that creates a
field or wrecks a building doesn't
actually have any tactical effect is a
shell thrown away so what the west is
trying to do is give them precision
weaponry
as you said they're running out of of
the old the old weaponry ammunition
thing is of course as we've said for
weeks now they're not getting enough the
amounts they're getting for example of
rocket artillery strikes deep into the
russian logistics rear absolutely
essential to stop the supply of russian
shells coming forward and strike russian
artillery headquarters the
gifts and supplies that west have been
supplying are insufficient they're a
drop in the ocean of what's required to
the point actually even beyond that of
somewhat derisory particularly in rocket
artillery
now quite a bit of of weaponry has been
promised by the west why is that
weaponry not reaching ukraine faster
frank
of course some of it isn't isn't it
hasn't even left the uh left the gifting
countries yet
that those which have some of it is
locked in bottlenecks so there are
supply bottlenecks in western ukraine i
understand
uh some of it has been struck by russian
rockets uh rocket attacks although i
don't think that's been decisive and
some of it's been eroded away treated as
it were on the battlefield as will
always happen because clearly since we
keep telling the russians of course what
we're sending their intelligence
officers say well okay we've got 98 m
triple seven houses to destroy destroyed
however many and so many left so we have
to stop telling them what we're sending
but anyway the point is
there are problems with the supply chain
but the biggest problem is that
the supplies aren't even leaving
western
borders
in sufficient quantities
now there are concerns about war fatigue
among western countries backing ukraine
do you see countries in europe and north
america in particular losing their
resolve to help ukraine win this war oh
that's such a such an important question
wars are won and lost primarily at home
we saw that in iraq for the british
americans and the others we saw it
especially in afghanistan more recently
the home front here in ukraine is secure
there's no question of ukrainians losing
their resolve at that strategic or
political level but as you've said there
the real home front is dc new york
berlin paris london
that's where the home front is and
that's where the resolve needs to be
firm
the risk is of course of of the west
getting bored with this which is uh
pathetic but nonetheless untrue and we
almost remember another thing russian
information operations are hard at work
trying to influence us at that strategic
level so now isn't the time for any kind
of defeatism
now is the time to press on give the
ukrainians what they want and show
steady resolve steady resolve at that
strategic level to ensure
that those that that home front remains
as firm as the ukrainian front because a
war lost in ukraine is a war lost for
the west and we cannot tolerate a failed
state with a big army and an angry
population in europe it's very very poor
for the future it would be a disaster
for us
frank thank you very much for your
analysis uh that was military analyst
frank ludwig there in oxford
thanks very much indeed
let's take a look at some other
developments in the war uh russia day
ceremonies have taken place in some
parts of occupied ukraine military bands
paraded in sevastopol in crimea which
moscow annexed in 2014
and russia's national colors were on
show in mariupol the port was overrun
after nearly three months under
bombardment
some former mcdonald's restaurants in
russia have reopened under a new name
which translates as tasty and that's it
not all customers are happy though
protester demanding the return of the
big mac disrupted the opening ceremony
in moscow
mcdonald's closed its 850 russian
outlets over the war